I grew up not seeing particularly well,
and I didn't know that I wasn't seeing
very well, but what I did know was
I wasn't doing well at school.
I got my first pair of glasses and
suddenly the world changed and I could
start to see the board at school,
I started to do well in my exams.
If my situation were different
this may have never happened.
I wanted to make sure that that
wasn't the case for anyone else.
Peak Vsion was owner of a challenge.
People who can provide eye care tend
to live in cities and towns and
people who are blind tend to live in
very rural difficult to reach areas,
particularly in low income
countries such as Kenya.
And so the real vision was to try and
connect the two using mobile technology.
Initially, we moved out to
Kenya to do some research,
which was setting up 100 clinics.
I looked at all of the stuff that I was
having to cut around in this eye clinic,
which is over $150,000 worth of care.
I thought can we try and
transform this into a technology
that's really portable and accessible.
So we went about redesigning every one
of the tests that were in the clinic
with either a small phone app or
piece of clip of hardware that
could sit on the small phone, and
allow it to be all performed on
a smart phone by a technician, so
without having to have expert healthcare
training using a configuration of
lenses and all sorts of complexities
that would make it possible to hold your
smart phone up, point it at someone's
eye, and get a view of the retina.
So we have a suite of
Peak applications here,
I'm going to show you the vision test.
So what we do here is, it'll give us
some on-screen instructions to stand
two meters from the patient, and
they'll get a letter E to look at.
They'll point in the direction of the E,
so this way it's going like that, so
we swipe on the phone accordingly.
Now the advantage here is the tester
doesn't need to see what's going on on
the screen, so they're just going to
swipe whichever way the patient is
pointing, even if they're giving
the right or wrong answer.
If they were to shake their head and
say they can't see, we can just shake
the device, now recorder not seen.
And once the test is finished I get a
vibration alert and a reading on screen.
And so what we can do is then view
their world based on our vision test
using our sight sim application,
which gives you the detected vision and
the normal vision, and it allows you
to walk around that person's visual
world and really understand
their level of sight impairment.
The initial build of this were
designed to be used within the study
that I had moved to Kenya for,
but one of the big things that we learn
if you create a tool that's easy to use,
it's low cost and is intuitive,
it's likely to be adopted in any market.
We often focus on impact in terms
of economics in the sense of,
how can I make money, or how can
we take money out of this, whereas
there's a huge economic value in terms
of giving somebody their sight back.
What we repeatedly saw in our clinics
in Kenya, is we'd have young children
supporting old parents or grandparents
who should've been in school.
So for that child it means they're
like to never break out poverty.
So moving the measure away from,
what can I take out of this,
to what could I put in, is a real way of
actually assessing the economic impact.
Then there's a huge number of areas
where mobile developers can add value.
I think it's almost limitless in terms
of the way we could improve things.
And by being able to contribute to
making other people's lives easier or
more efficient, you can then have
a huge knock-on effect on hundreds,
thousands, millions of other people.